good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight houston texas is one of
the rare nice big cities left in this
country a little hot in the summer but
great people very pretty neighborhoods
and a lot going on thanks to the energy
sector biotech and aerospace houston has
an enormous and still robust economy it
is hardly some dying mill town in the
northeast or the upper midwest your kids
might want to move to houston someday
maybe after college it's not baltimore
but all of a sudden houston texas is
starting to look a little bit more like
baltimore crime in houston has gotten
scary the murder right there has risen
by more than 50 percent in just the last
year
it's bad here's a local news report a
deadly start to the year across houston
police investigating at least 41
homicides through 24 days so far this
year houston has more murders than new
york city los angeles even chicago it's
one of those things where i'm fearful
for my family just to go out the house
the president of the houston police
officers union frustrated if it keeps up
this pace we'll be well over 500 murders
this year
i'm fearful just for my family to go
outside of the house as you heard that
was the president of the police union in
houston so
he would know
it's amazing this is happening in all
places in houston and what's so telling
about this crime wave is how recently it
began
murders in houston started to spike in a
big way after joe biden became president
why is that exactly very simple answer
joe biden opened the southern border
texas shares more than 1200 miles of
border with mexico there is a brutal
cartel war
underway in mexico right now it's been
going on for a long time many of the
combatants in that war have now moved
north into texas they brought drugs with
them they've also brought machine guns
this fall a felon opened fire on houston
police officers with a fully automatic
rifle now you hear a lot about assault
weapons but the truth is authorities
don't see fully automatic weapons very
often they are heavily regulated and
typically they're owned by collectors
but automatic weapons are very common in
war zones and there is a war in mexico
so with no border in place the cartels
are bringing their armaments here watch
this fire fight in houston
dion it's houston police let's do this
that's automatic weapons fire
it sounds like syria or mexico
but it's an apartment complex in houston
texas we can go on if you know anybody
who lives in houston call and ask how's
your city changed recently and they'll
tell you
open borders did this houston didn't do
it to itself this was done to houston
and not just to houston to so many
places across this country where
millions of illegal aliens have flooded
in during joe biden's presidency on
monday for example more than a hundred
illegal haitian migrants landed in the
florida keys in a single boat
you're watching aerial footage from
summerlin key florida
pictures like this are no longer
uncommon in the state of florida
the world is coming to america's shores
why because they're fully aware that the
bide administration is rewarding foreign
nationals for violating our federal
immigration law
it is an invasion
huge numbers of americans are dying as a
result of that invasion a hundred
thousand dead last year of drug ods most
were killed by fentanyl that is trucked
in for mexico across open borders
long term there are massive labor market
disruptions there is evaporating social
cohesion and so on
the costs of this have been beyond
calculating and this is exactly why no
sane country opens its borders ever
ever anywhere what joe biden is doing
right now has never been done
and it's about to get much worse we're
not guessing currently a trump area
regulation called title 42 allows the
border patrol to turn illegal migrants
back to mexico on the grounds that
there's a pandemic in progress so we
probably shouldn't let millions of
people infected with kovid move here
without permission seems sensible but
according to democrats this rule is
racist because it might slow the human
wave of migration so for months they've
been demanding the biden administration
suspend this rule
watch them whine
i urge president biden and secretary
mayorkas to immediately put a stop to
these expulsions and to end this title
42 policy at our southern border
that we cannot continue these hateful
and xenophobic trump policies in
addition a relic title 42
exists
it is a relic of the trump
administration it was created to be
mean-spirited
title 43 i asked for a suspension of it
i urge the bidet administration and my
colleagues to remember the refugees who
are waiting at our border
kept out by the cruel and unnecessary
title 42 policy look title 42 is being
used
in a way that i think is indiscriminate
uh and that violates the basic essence
of our law but this process that the
bible administration has continued from
the trump administration
in my mind is inexcusable
so your kid has to wear a mask in school
but illegal aliens get to come here with
no restrictions at all despite the fact
they may be infected with covet because
otherwise you're a racist
that's the case they were making and so
finally inevitably the bide
administration has caved turns out even
trying to maintain basic public health
standards is unacceptable if it gets in
the way of increasing mass immigration
title 42 is being nullified a similar
rule you should know will still apply to
you american citizens are not exempt to
this day you as a citizen are not
allowed to return to the united states
without permission from the cdc michelle
wellensky will sign off on that so
coming back to the country you were born
in is no longer your birthright but
illegal aliens now face no barriers at
all
and of course they know it everyone
knows it's not their fault
it's our president's fault according to
axios quote u.s intelligence officials
are privately bracing for a massive
influx of more than 170 000 migrants at
the mexico border now that title 42 is
ending
so the wave grows the total
transformation of this country
accelerates
so we've been very passive in the face
of this people make grumpy noises about
it no one's done anything how should we
respond well the same way we respond to
any other invasion with the us military
that's why countries have militaries to
stop invasions and this would not be a
hard invasion to stop our military could
seal the border with mexico in days that
would save american lives it would
restore order and it would end the
invasion
does that sound crazy like a misuse of
the us military well keep in mind that
nancy pelosi called in the u.s military
to protect her from trump voters at the
u.s capitol she treated our soldiers
like her personal security detail
and then of course at this very moment
we are sending thousands of american
troops and billions in the military
american military hardware to eastern
europe to help the ukrainians restore
their borders
so the obvious question is why not here
why not take america's safety or family
safety as seriously as nancy pelosi
takes her own safety
that seems like a fair question probably
not russian disinformation probably an
honest question
we spoke to congresswoman maria salazar
of miami last night and we asked that
question of her
she refused to answer watch how she
refused
i just can't help notice the contrast
between your desire to send migs to
ukraine to preserve its borders but not
here should we send the u.s military to
the mexican border since you have
admitted that tens of millions of people
have come here illegally that our
borders are porous they're not defended
they are open
should we send the us military to the
mexican border
that is what i have created a whole plan
so we can really seal the border because
you know what would you my community
would you call it
let me finish
in america
i'm asking questions about borders
all of us are appalled by the violation
of ukraine's borders
you don't seem as appalled by the
violation of our borders by tens of
millions of people so let me ask you for
the third time sure
military representation okay then would
you support the u.s military
securing the united states border
tonight or on the same timetable as
sending migs to ukraine how about that
uh that's hypothetical again
oh it's hypothetical i've got a plan
right how many plans have you heard
about from republicans for say the past
25 years
many many many
to restate
this is a highly dangerous situation
that the bite administration has placed
our country in
mexico
whatever its merits is in the middle of
a war
not a new war a war that has raged on
for more than a decade a war that has
likely killed more than a hundred
thousand people so far
you're seeing footage on your screen
right now of trucks burning in the town
of nueva laredo that's just feet from
the u.s border in the state of texas
what you're looking at is the aftermath
of a three-hour gun battle between
cartels and government forces
you'll notice the situation there is so
chaotic that the trucks just burn in the
middle of the road no one comes to put
out the fires to restore order to arrest
anyone
so that's not a law enforcement action
that's a war that's what wars are like a
few years ago the sinaloa cartel used
heavy machine guns and armored vehicles
to win a pitched battle against the
mexican military
that's a war a civil war
feat from our border
that's the country joe biden opened our
border to it's insanity
and yet somehow our congress cannot be
bothered to notice this any of it
even as millions stream across
murder victims in houston apparently
don't have influential social media
accounts so kevin mccarthy doesn't know
that they exist
and that's a shame because when he sees
it on tick tock he acts
here's mccarthy demanding we send
military equipment across the world to
stop the invasion of another country
watch
when you think about
what president biden should do
i think there's a bipartisan movement
right here provide them the migs
provide them the planes where they can
create a no-fly zone provide them the
armament that they need to continue
to fight a
war that they did not create
so mccarthy says of the ukrainians it's
a war they didn't create and that is
certainly true the ukrainians did not
create that where the ukrainians did not
invade their own country
but we didn't either we didn't invade
our own country very few americans
wanted to open our border to a narco
state in the middle of a drug war joe
biden did that to us
and no one cares
so maybe we need our own zilenski to get
the world's attention and stop the
invasion of america who will that be hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else